I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation tonight
this is not a bluff the citizens of
Russia can rest assured that the
territorial Integrity of our motherland
our independence and freedom will be
defended I repeat by all the systems
available to us Russians belarusians
ukrainians shuvash mordovians all of
them are Russians against you we will
defeat you you will never win not on
your life
grab
the United States will never
never recognize Russia's claims on
Ukraine Sovereign territory we will not
rest
we cannot
we will not allow President Putin to get
away with it Putin Bears full
responsibility for this war and it is
his responsibility to end it
and always remember Ukraine existed
before this enemy appeared and Ukraine
will exist after it
Rockets are raining down on the
Ukrainian capital in retaliation for the
successful sabotage of Russia's bridge
to the Crimea
the recent Ukrainian advantages far from
deterring Putin seem to have provoked
the Russian leader into digging in for a
long drawn-out conflict his new military
Commander's record comes stained with
the Carnage of Russia's campaign in
Syria
[Music]
the West's leaders say that they will
stand behind Ukraine Come What May and
that no privations we Face could match
what ukrainians are suffering
but many worry that neither Kiev nor the
Kremlin will settle for anything short
of Victory our choice can we make peace
with Putin or are we in a war Without
End in the next 30 minutes we go in
search of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight Lord Barrack Kim Derek
former British Ambassador to United
States and who was also the United
Kingdom National Security advisor
the Ukrainian MP Alessia vasilenko and
Evelyn Farkas former assistant deputy
secretary of defense in the Obama
Administration
we know that we are at a serious moment
we know that Western countries have put
their weight behind Ukraine but it looks
like some decisions are going to have to
be made so let me start with all three
of you and ask you a simple question I
guess
is it possible to make peace with
President Putin still in place Kim darok
I think it's it's very difficult to
Trevor
um he has attacked uh a neighbor
completely unprovoked a neighbor that
presented no sort of threat to Russia
he's rained down death and destruction
on the country
set aside the military casualties six
thousand more than six thousand
Ukrainian civilians killed
um and he is continuing to prosecute
prosecute the war with extreme brutality
um I find it hard now to conceive how
any country can have any sort of normal
relationship
um with this leader in the light of what
he is what he's done uh it seems to me
that that
uh Pariah status is is deserved and
likely to be uh to be permanent
Evelyn Farkas can you see
a resolution of any kind with Putin
still in office
well Trevor I think that peace can be
forced upon Vladimir Putin that is to
say if the Ukrainian military pushes
Russia out of Ukraine there will be
peace short of that Vladimir Putin is
not going to give up as long as he is in
power on his revanchist neo-imperial
vision for himself and for the Russian
Federation which includes essentially
control over Ukraine and then Georgia
Moldova the whole former Soviet space
and and some influence also over Eastern
Europe and then if you can go beyond
that destroying NATO and weakening the
United States so
um as long as Vladimir Putin is in power
he's going to continue to try to achieve
those objectives and if we come up with
some kind of compromise on the
battlefield with him in power I'm afraid
that will only be a ceasefire not a true
peace
in the end it will be the Ukrainian
People's Choice I guess about whether
there is a resolution of any kind well
come on to talk about what might be
possible but can you and see a situation
in which Ukraine could accept any kind
of resolution with uh Vladimir Putin
still in place
uh well there has to be a lot of ifs uh
for that to to become a reality and if
if Putin agrees to those of us then of
course uh there can be a piece and these
ifs include demilitarizing Russia uh
these includes uh denuclearizing Russia
Jesus include uh revoking all the
legislative system in Russia which has
led to the possibility of this
aggression which include uh the
trampling down on the freedom of speech
on various human rights and uh on
essentially creating a media propaganda
that that made this aggression possible
um if Putin agrees to to these
Provisions well you know why not but
before that before we actually sit down
and think about a a peace agreement and
the terms of this peace agreement first
and foremost Russia needs to get out of
Ukraine of the territory of Ukraine and
all of the territories of Ukraine need
to be liberated and back under the
Ukrainian flag and when I say all I also
mean uh the Crimean peninsula
um if I'm hearing you properly less here
the the chances of the thing the list of
things you've uh just set out actually
occurring are roughly zero
you hear me absolutely correctly I don't
see how uh Putin uh given his Ambitions
his imperialistic Ambitions how he can
concede to any one of these points
um so that is why president zielinski
has clearly uh stated that a peace
agreement with Putin is is impossible
and there will be no peace agreement was
put and signed we are realists at the
end of the day in Ukraine and we
understand that
um that there will probably be another
representative of Russia signing off on
the peace agreement okay so where was it
we've already established some common
ground which is not gonna happen with
Putin in place so let's put that let's
put him for one moment to one side uh
though I suspect he'll pop up again in
this discussion
um let's talk about what the price of
not reaching a deal might be ever in
Focus if there is no deal
what happens
well I think I guess you mean by some
sort of resolution look what's at stake
right now Trevor is nothing short of the
international order because Vladimir
Putin is trying to rewrite Ukrainian
history and essentially erase Ukraine
off the face of the map he's already
tried to alter borders using military
force starting in 2014 when he annexed
Crimea illegally and now of course he's
trying to do go beyond that and the
International Community needs to stand
up for the order that we established
after World War II in order to prevent
World War III because if you recall what
I said in answer to your first question
Putin will turn around and try to
destroy NATO if he tries to destroy NATO
then we're looking at basically World
War III again so there's a great deal at
stake here and we have to find some sort
of resolution and my belief is the only
resolution is to defeat Putin in Ukraine
militarily so that he is defeated at
least in his political objective which
likely will mean of course that he is no
longer in power in Moscow Kim Derek do
you agree with that that the only uh
Pathway to let's call it resolution is
80 feet a military defeat I think you
you mean Evelyn for uh Putin and for
Russia
Trevor I basically agree with everything
that Evelyn has said but since you're
inviting us to to speculate can you just
make this point
um and I do it in a spirit of
exceptional admiration for the bravery
and skill with which the Ukrainian Army
has conducted this war and for the
brilliant leadership that Selinsky has
provided but ukrainians who are
Prosecuting who are who are defending
their country who are fighting this war
they're getting a lot of equip military
equipment especially in the United
States I think we're second in line in
terms of supplying it
um but it's through premiums are doing
it so we in the west have to recognize
that that it is the Ukrainian leadership
between people who call the shots on
this and as long as they want to
continue to fight uh to drive the
Russians out of their country then they
need they deserve and need our 120
support if there comes a moment
somewhere down the track where there is
um such sort of exhaustion uh at the
wall which may be you know this war can
go on for a long time uh and you know
the Ukrainian leadership decide to go
for some sort of peace deal we in the
west can't determine what that is for
them I don't think we can offer them
advice we can offer them views
ultimately it's for them to the sign
language Let me let's take up what Kim
Derek has just said and let me put this
to you it's pretty easy for us in the
west you know I'm sitting here in London
to be heroic
about the sacrifice of your people but
your people are dying
how long can this go on for
until the very last Soldier Russian
soldier leaves Ukrainian soil and
Ukrainian people have been very clear
about this we are clear about this when
we talk to each other when we have these
discussions in our homes when we have
these discussions in our communities and
we are also very clear about this one we
speak to to our International partner
partners and on various media platforms
there can be uh no other way if Ukraine
was to cease territories or uh go into
some kind of compromise or
um otherwise just put down our hands and
stop fighting immediately Putin will use
this opportunity to wipe off a whole
nation of 44 million Nation off the pace
of the ass this is his strategy this is
how he rebuilds the big Russian Empire
and essentially this means that
ukrainians will have zero chance of
surviving if we stand up and fight and
if we continue fighting we at least have
that chance of surviving and I think in
230 days we have proved that we are
doing quite well if we get more weapons
and I I hope that that's not an if but
that's a when we will start getting
larger amounts of weapons ammunition to
go with when we will be getting the
fighter jets that we need the air
defense system the modern High uh
sophistication uh air defense systems
that is when we can make this Victory
happen faster and we need a quick
victory for the sake of Ukraine so that
ukrainians stop dying but we also need
this victory for the sake of the whole
world so that we can go back to
stability so that we can go back to
thinking long-term peace and strategic
development in the conditions of
long-term peace rather than in the
conditions of War well let me put this
to you then you say to the last Soldier
and that means I think to the last
Ukrainian citizen
um
a year ago the rest of us not the
ukrainians but the rest of us didn't
take him seriously when he said this is
what's going to happen because Belarus
and Ukraine are really part of Russia
we should I suspect take him seriously
when he says that it is possible
that he might use what they call
Battlefield nuclear weapons now I'm not
going to ask you what the Ukrainian
response to that would be what I'd
really like to know is what you think
the West should do in the event that he
realizes that threat
I think that the West should prevent the
realization of that threat a nuclear
attack is not just one man uh in the
Kremlin person pushing one button it uh
takes time to prepare it takes time to
prepare the deployment of those weapons
and the uh intelligence systems are
sophisticated enough to be able to use
prevention mechanism and when Ukraine
gave up its nuclear Arsenal back in 1996
we signed a piece of paper called The
Budapest memorandum I would be calling
it an agreement under other
circumstances but it so happens that
Russia one of the countries that signed
up with the best memorandum actually
breached an undetacked Ukraine so I
would say that if any International
Agreements are still doing anything it
would be up to the US up to the UK up to
the other nuclear powers to actually
have a preventive reaction rather than a
reaction after the nuclear attack itself
happens okay Evelyn Focus then came
directly what should we be doing now to
respond to what Leslie has just said
well I agree with what Lucia said the
upshot of it being that we need to work
now to prevent Putin from taking any
kind of action that involves the use of
military of nuclear power
um and that means we have to deter Putin
we have to do what it sounds like
President Biden and his administration
is doing which is clearly communicating
to the Russians the consequences the
cost of of using a nuclear weapon at the
end of the day that will be the first
use of a nuclear weapon even if it's
just a detonation at no Target in the
context of a war since World War II the
International Community I believe would
be outraged and that would include
um you know Russia's putitative partner
China as well as the Indian government
and many other governments around the
world at that point I think the game
would shift and the U.S would probably
directly use military conventional
military means against Vladimir Putin's
military
and I think the International Community
would conclude that Vladimir Putin has
no right to helm a government within our
on our globe having used nuclear nuclear
materials or or you know used a nuclear
weapons so to be clear here Evelyn we
are talking regime change
yes I think again any government that
uses a nuclear weapon for the first time
since World War II in the context of a
war you know people say in Anger
whatever whether you're angry or not
um does not deserve to be in power and I
think the International Community would
decide that that was the case
and find some way to engineer regime
change yes
can that
yeah I agree with I agree with that I
think that so far the U.S Administration
divide Administration
has actually handled this this rather
well I think two particular strengths
have been first of all the way that they
used intelligence material to call out
Russian preparations for the attack and
remake this
public throughout the world that this
was about to happen and uh as everyone
said a lot of people didn't really
believe it would but but the
intelligence analysts were right and I
think that the response which I think
Jake Sullivan the National Security
advisor was one of the main voices in
this uh the the message that the
American Administration has sent about
the response should Putin use tactical
nuclear weapons
um has been exactly right some ambiguity
in it so put him can't be exactly sure
what would happen and sort of start
calibrating for it but also a very clear
message that the the consequences would
be would be immense and immensely agree
for for the Russian Administration
um
grave the threat of grave consequences
don't seem to have stopped him
uh doing what he's doing I mean frankly
he doesn't seem to be isn't that
bothered about uh the tens of thousands
of deaths uh that he's visited on his
own people uh do you really believe
let's say I'll come to you do you really
believe that um
the the West saying these things
are going to stop
whether it's Putin or someone else in
the Kremlin Prosecuting the war in the
way they have done
saying these things shows an intention
so it is already a first step but then
that intention needs to be followed
through with action and there needs to
be a preparedness from Western leaders
to actually go in with the action I
think that first and foremost the
importance is to strengthen Ukraine's
defensibility because Putin only
understands the the language of force
and if there is a force that can be
reckoned with Russia and uh if there's a
force that can be pushed that can push
back his military and have him as well
and his political uh strategy towards
Ukraine then uh yes he will start
Reckoning with it and if that means
removing Putin uh and I I think this is
the way that that this world needs to be
going if we are to be reinstating
long-term peace but one thing that I
don't agree that was said uh just
previously uh is uh that a loss uh that
the victory for Ukraine will mean a loss
for Russia no it will mean a loss for
but definitely not for Russia actually a
victory for Ukraine will also be a
victory for Russia that is for the
hundreds of millions of Russians living
uh in that vast territory because that
will actually give them a chance at
freedom and a trained statement of the
human rights I don't think that um the
the 145 million Uh Russian population is
um is deserving enough to live under
this uh autocratic ruler and under this
regime and I think that by providing a
victory for Ukraine we will also be
providing a victory under freedom for
the 145 million Russian Nation
we're all moving pretty much uh to the
same conclusion that there is a way out
of this and that is if
somehow the west or indeed the Russian
people show Mr Putin the door and that
he's removed from the equation that's in
a way the first thing
um let's take him out of uh out of
discussion for the moment and then talk
about what might constitute a way of
resolving the conflict uh with whoever
happens to be uh in the Russian
leadership
think the West could offer Russia
uh that would persuade it to back off
really
well if we take Vladimir Putin out of
the conversation and assume that we have
a more pragmatic government in place
ideally we would like a government
that's not hostile to the United States
and to Nato and to all of our partners
around the world the government that
accepts the international order and in
that case if if the government is truly
looking out for the interests of the
Russian people and defending the
international order and the principles
of sovereignty our work will be
relatively easy we will have to then
work to help this Russian government
reform politically and economically
essentially finishing the work that we
started after the Soviet Union fell
apart but was really frankly interrupted
maybe wasn't was faultly conducted or in
insufficiently
um you know the West assistance was
insufficient at the time so we we could
that would be the most optimistic
scenario something less than that would
be a not web Western friendly but
pragmatic
Elite group of people who are close to
Vladimir Putin today but don't have the
same you know neo-imperial
um passion
um and are willing to accept the borders
of the Russian Federation in 2014. but
Evelyn do you think that's really
realistic because one of the things that
we do know about Russia are the Russian
people I should say is that the collapse
of the Soviet Union was a source of
great resentment and frankly if you look
at the you know the attitudes towards
Gorbachev who's seen as your architect
of that you're talking about the people
who basically
share some of Mr Putin's views about the
place of Russia so the whole idea that
we might get to a new regime that you
know
kind of goes completes the work of
1989-92
is that really realistic
well really quickly I'm going to try to
quickly summarize history
Gorbachev when he dismantled the Soviet
Union or when he allowed it to collapse
he didn't really have a vision for how
to change what was left and he did not
have an idea I mean he was trying to
reform the existing Soviet system which
was unreformable so that the tragedy of
Gorbachev was that he didn't know what
came next all right Kim
what do you think
um
since your your invite years to sort of
look into the future Trevor when
um when uh Putin is gone when some more
acceptable more pragmatic
um uh former government is is emerging
in Russia maybe with some democracy as
part of it
uh I just often choose two potential
specifics neither of which is really new
somewhere down the track once Russia has
withdrawn completely from Crimea from uh
from Ukraine and once they have I
imagine got into accepted they have to
pay more reparations and this kind of
thing
um I think there are two things that
that the West can do to build a new
relationship with a new Russia
um one is that remember back in the days
of uh the United States and Soviet
unions the two great superpowers there
were a whole raft of agreements about
arms control
um whether on strategic nuclear weapons
or on conventional forces or
intermediate nuclear weapons and we
could certainly I would have thought go
back into that Arena and see where there
are ways in which you could reduce
arms maybe all kinds nuclear and
conventional and forces in in Europe a
deal between between the um between the
US and you and Russia all between NATO
and Russia the other is around the term
the early 2000s we were building
structures with a time a very weak uh
Russia which were binding them into an
attempt to bind them into Western
structures in particular I remember a
NATO Russia Council will be set up
didn't really get anywhere and maybe we
in the west didn't try hard enough for
that time to make these structures work
but you could have another go at that
okay and see if you can find some
structures which will involve Russia
which would basically rule out the
possibility of this kind of thing
happening again because I say that's
both a long way down the track after
you've got Russia completely out of
Ukraine and done what it will need to do
in terms of reparations and the rest of
it to the term what they've done
last word really um
is there anything short of the list that
you gave us earlier on you know the
Putin gone Russian's gone from Ukrainian
soil denuclearization potentially
democracy is there anything short of
that that you think brings an end to
this
uh well uh let me let me structure it a
little
bit uh because there's a a necessary
consequence as to how uh this piece can
be achieved so first uh everything
starts with a victory was a victory for
Ukraine and its allies that means as we
have correctly identified all the
Russians gone from all the Russia all
the Ukrainian territory Crimea included
the national has concluded uh all of the
Ukrainian territory the Ukrainian
borders are reinstated to their 1991
internationally recognized format and
then after this starts the
um the the points that make sure that
Russia can never again be repeating the
same crime the crime of aggression and
this is where uh we're talking about
responsibility
for the international crimes committed
by Russia war crimes crimes against
humanity this is why we are talking
about tribunals this is where we're
talking about uh bringing people before
the international criminal court the
international court of justice and this
is where the operations uh start to be
discussed and reparations that need to
be paid to Ukraine the Ukrainian people
for all the damage and loss but also to
all the countries that stood by Ukraine
and that invested in this new framework
of defense and security of global
defense and security and these
operations this is something that we
really need to give a big a big think
about so that uh the Russian people
still are in full awareness of the wrong
that they did maybe for generations to
come but also that they do not push them
overboard to sort of start a new war
again and elect a new leader who who
will try to to bring back greatness to
Russia so it's not about humiliation
it's not even about Justice it's about
really making making sure that Russia is
incapacitated and that it can never
again rebuild the Army and the nuclear
Arsenal with which it can think of
attacking Ukraine or any other country
for that matter thank you very much
indeed normally at this point of the
program I try to see if there is some
common ground between those who have
spoken well interestingly
there's there seems to me to be complete
Common Ground between the three of you
literally this can't be resolved with
Putin in place or to be more precise
Putin in power
this can't be resolved unless the
Russians essentially uh take their tanks
off uh Ukrainian soil and that there
would then have to be some guarantees
about uh the Russian power nuclear
weapons and so on and reparations and
Justice it's quite a Big Bill and I
think the one definite piece of common
ground that you have uh between user
right now the Kremlin isn't going to pay
that bill and that the strategy of
Victory is the only one available for
the west and for Ukraine look I want to
thank all three of you for really
absorbing conversation now stay with us
we'll have all of today's news coming up
after the break
foreign
[Music]